refugees Trump supporters Muslims
soldiers since we began in 2010 we've
always wanted to give a voice to the
vast spectrum of people who I felt
judged or left out of the conversation
today we live an incredibly divided time
but what would it look like to be a part
of a movement for empathy when we
launched our apparel brand we wanted it
to symbolize this movement a community
of good humans worldwide that believe in
coming together through understanding
first rather than judging with our
latest collection we're giving back a
portion of profits to amazing people all
around the world that are taking a stand
for the innate human goodness within us
all we're collecting your stories of
incredible people doing good things and
we'll be choosing some of them we can
give back to whether or not you buy
anything we're deeply grateful for your
support and wherever you are we invite
you to join our movement of living every
day with a little more empathy enjoy the
episode
I did so many drugs and my really early
developing years so that was my fault
whether you want to talk about it was my
genes fault that I just my genes made me
take pills and put them in my body you
could I guess argue that there is a
genetic component switch those are not
in my control and addictions in my
family but yeah that's why I'm here
no I like because I'm sober now so like
if I did it right it's weird because
like at first I don't know if it was but
now if I like if I decide to take a
drink or if I decide to do drugs like
I'm I know what I'm doing like I know
what I'm getting myself into this is my
choice if I want to go ahead and take
that drug urge or you know whatever it
is nobody put a gun in my head and made
me take a drink or get high so that's
why I strongly agree that taking a drug
is my choice another day I think for
some people it's the environment because
some people are born into households
where parents suffer from drug addiction
parents suffer from alcoholism and in
more disadvantaged neighborhoods where I
come from you see a lot of mothers you
know getting like their next fix you
know in like 30 minutes in front of
their children but for me personally
I've suffered my addiction from going to
parties going out and this alcohol count
is like being ya guys okay well damn I
can't even say I'm sober now okay [ __ ]
all right anyway oh yeah so I feel like
it's a matter of self control influence
and environment but I think for the most
part for me personally its self control
because honestly you put a line of coke
in front of me right now I'm gonna sniff
it but like you know I think what I did
started what I have I'm food addictions
by the way
spoiler alert just so you all know when
I was younger I saw so many
opportunities to better myself and to
look better and to be better and I would
take all of them I would take advantage
of everything I would skip meals I would
go to the gym until I couldn't see and
so this social pressure did kind of
influence me a little bit to start with
like eating disorders you know binging
purging I mean it got to the point where
I was eating multiple meals and then
purging them if that's not addiction
I cannot even yeah the holidays how is
that your fault though I think it's from
the habits that I started myself I mean
I chose to do it myself
you saw the way it was I knew exactly
what belief saw the world and how
damaging it was you know I know how
damaging food can be I chose those
behaviors I have to live with the
repercussions
I don't think addiction is a disease I
do think it's more of a conviction
because necessarily saying I said the
disease means that it spreads therefore
if I personally me my favorite drug is
hallucinogens so if I were to
hallucinate that's saying oh you're
gonna do it you're gonna do it you're
gonna do it you know I think it's like a
genetic thing like I like I have like
our addiction runs and like or like
alcoholism like runs in my family
and you know I rarely ever meet people
where they're like I'm the only one in
my family you think you were like [ __ ]
from the jump like from birth like you
were just this you know I never thought
I was like [ __ ] from Joe I mean that's
the thing is like I didn't choose it
it's not a choice if it was my choice
then I wouldn't be here I you know every
day my brains trying to kill me and
that's just the way it goes but I just
got to live with it and that's just I
don't want it but I got it
I don't know position in your head like
the psychology of thinking about as a
disease never really helped me yes you
can be predisposed to genes what's
helped me is like mmm I don't know
medicine and information hey never
helped me because they're like just
trust this thing and that switch never
liked click believe me I want it to
referring to it as a disease kind of
like associating everyone in that room
and a negative association if it does
keep you clean I'm Wade pro using that
word a toy relays so it's not there's no
right or wrong on this I think everybody
has their own whatever works for them
you know what I mean
totally agree I usually compare it to
heart disease because it's like you
don't choose to have it genetics have a
lot to do with it and so does your
lifestyle I mean those are basically the
ingredients to the formula of a disease
anyways I mean heart disease is not
spread about neither is addiction but I
think it's like totally a disease when
you talk about how it affects people how
it presents itself you know how it
starts I think that a lot of it is very
similar
whatever I mean to find gateway drug
yeah you everyone who's done any drug
ever literally has a drug they did
before that so you just get demon
gateway drug drugs that purposely lead
to other drugs I would say absolutely
not I mean I thought caffeine can be a
gateway drug to adderall I mean I was in
college I mean we out get quad shots of
Starbucks and like drink it until I'm
vibrating
but I mean 'ln and other people are like
wow that's just not as effective anymore
I'm gonna do some adderall you know I
mean it's kind of like anything can be a
gateway drug and I think it's just I
don't think a gateway drug is what
people think it is well he must love to
do like black and white behavior like
this or that [ __ ] flame to Nana and
it's like to blame to an inanimate
object with such a complex issue like
addictive behavior is insane yeah -
literally blame like a substance like a
more accurate one would be like if
you're [ __ ] sad and lonely and scared
and fearful and you smoke weed you may
do heroin at some point in your life but
not likely that would be like an okay
thing for me to see I would be like
that's probably true but not like if you
smoke weed you're [ __ ]
well that's also why a lot of people
aren't complete heroin junkies even
though they've gotten premium opiates
from the hospital during a surgery I
mean it's not a gateway drug you don't
just go in and you're like oh man I had
a taste of that I've got to go do heroin
now like you don't I mean you're missing
that vital reason to chase the drug I
mean if you're giving it for actual pain
at the hospital you don't decide that
you want to go out and do heroin when
you're done I mean most people don't
anyways
I do
[Music]
yeah personally I feel I don't like
being called an addict Oh like someone
see me walking down the street oh that
oh she does hard drugs huh you know I
just feel like if you everyone has
something that they partake in and I
feel like just labeling someone ask that
it's just morally offensive to me I
think it's also the term I mean it's got
like a really negative connotation and
while I agree that I have an addiction
to be labeled as an addict am i
comfortable with that no especially as a
male with an eating disorder because
that is totally like criminalized I mean
men cannot be weak men cannot I mean
that's like a very feminine thing you
know it's really hard to tell anyone
about it because you automatically feel
less I'm fine with feeling bad I think I
should feel bad about it I like it
because I start if I started drinking
it'll be three weeks before I'll start
throwing up and then I'll have to quit
for like three days just to feel good to
get back to drinking that's [ __ ]
addictive that's not like partying too
much that's you know choking down vodka
in the morning and I do feel bad about
it and I'm okay with feeling bad about
that it's [ __ ] embarrassing should
feel bad I just know I don't give a [ __ ]
what people call me like I mean I'm a
bunch of [ __ ] you know what I mean but
like it's not it doesn't like define me
as a person but it's just part of like
who I am so I like I don't you know
Harley good I don't care like yeah and
like you said like if I meet somebody
and I'm you know and they're like hey
I'm struggling with this I'm like yo me
too I feel the same thing then it
actually helps you know then it's like
I'm like you know I can I can be like oh
I did that and this is how I dealt with
that
yeah but notice how you said that what
hey I'm struggling with this yeah not I
am a blank addict
you know it just sounds so much harsher
I mean I think it's the negative
connotation that's you're labeling
yourself also with that I feel like I
can't like saying your label in that
spectrum you're putting yourself in a
category and no one person is you have
to put themselves in a bubble of
contract meant or mental contraption
just because that's what other people
want you to do I mean I just just don't
get like I mean no I know I mean I mean
I know like minority of like not like I
just you know I just don't really if
someone's calling me I mean I'm in a
daze and now to remind myself and I fool
myself one day that I'm not an addict
and I go out to get high like my friend
does cuz he doesn't have a problem I'm
gonna die so I'm okay with him being
reminded that I haven't added because
that's how a person I don't care how
they're gonna feel about me that's back
and that's out of my control
I don't know anybody personally who is
Dodie surprisingly I know a lot of
people who probably will in the
not-so-distant future but I don't know
anybody yet that's fair only 24 so we'll
see I think it's really important to
note the fact that while someone may not
pass away because of how much drugs they
took but how crushing their addiction
actually was to their mental health and
they may have decided to commit suicide
did I lose someone to addiction
absolutely did the drug actually kill
them no but I mean it drove them to kill
themselves six days ago with eleven
years my first friend passed away sorry
sorry um yeah my first printed pathway
this to an overdose it was 11 years ago
six days ago and I took my responsibly
for it because I got him high for the
first time on ecstasy high for the first
time in opiates and that was a wake-up
call for me like you know and then um
after that when I went to rehab I lost
over 30 friends to suicide or addiction
so yeah I know a lot I feel personally
like when I got into recovery that was
the one thing I did not expect my life
got better got way better but I started
building relationships with people
genuine friendships with them and then
getting close with them and he's became
my best friends and they started you
know dropping like one-night attend my
first friend passed away I got tattooed
right here and then eventually I just
can't keep getting tattoos for friends
that passed away
I have I had a friend who has been too
impatient rehabilitation five times in
the past three years and she's doing
better but I the first for sure didn't
work so I don't necessarily think that
they're like a foolproof way of fixing
someone who has an addiction to
something well they're very foolproof
ways to do anything and it's not even
really debatable they work for tons and
tons of people of course they work they
do amazing [ __ ] if you want it and
you're going to get the tools that you
need and you build the community as you
get then yeah you can stay sober if not
it's not gonna work for somebody's wants
this over a period here where you go
jail will keep somebody sober if I could
live in rehab I would because everything
is like they're like you wake up at this
time you eat at this time you talk about
your feelings at this time and then when
you get out you're like it's not you
know you have your whole [ __ ] life
like that's like unstructured and weird
and they help you give the like tools to
figure out like how to navigate that
life but if they're not there with you
100% of the time like it's up to you you
know you got to talk to about your
feelings who do I talk to when you're
out yeah everybody y'all you know we
love to hear it I think I'm one of a
strongly disagree side because I do
agree with you guys how it's like you
have to want to be sober and maybe I
don't want to be 100% sober at this
point but the programs that I've tried I
tried hospitalized I've tried counseling
a trach community-based a lot of them
are really clicky and my clicky I mean
like you know some this group associated
with this group you're an outcast you
know it's like an episode of Mean Girls
or something and so there should be more
structure there should be more jobs open
in that facility with people who are
licensed to influence others and make
them want to do better I don't want them
to be like be like guts we're sober tell
me why I should be sober tell me why I
should love my life tell me why I should
stop doing what I'm doing and I don't
feel like the substitute program at
least ones that I want to they have
instilled that
upon me I have a strong disagreement
with recovery houses you know the whole
way recovery is going on in LA but I
think at the end a if the person really
wants to get sober
or free from the addiction and then they
go to a reputable place that has helped
them before has helped somebody before
and they take that all in to learn new
tools to stay sober instead of getting
high
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much for watching that episode
guys just to remind her to check out our
apparel at the website linked below
we're so grateful that we get to do this
for you guys and we do want to you know
make this movement a larger thing with
you guys so whether or not you buy any
of the merch join the movement help us
live a little bit more with empathy
every day and was here on the next
episode
[Applause]